[Applause]
[Music]
bring you thank you
so there are pulley we know here
can be unbridled efficient and pensions
[Music]
your
content
between
[Music]
don't let us down and pity
our movie well  is I our
and you
between
yes price
[Music]
the
sat there pensions
[Music]
you
now
[Music]
the
now
mr
[Music]
guys
[Applause]
ok before leaving you guys who is  the
motor wie zb there and kies and my
alexis here dance and is specially
and sticks and or your baby yes hips and
right
ok and your new york per fish is the
central desk and this is the
intex and that make you with frank wright
ok so  is it super
who can play a role howa hitten guetta
ok then blew set something want easy
youtube channel while you do it bad
data
[Music]
do
libie
[Music]
do
people
[Music]
how people who
very
[Music]
no
have to make
[Music]
do
bmw
[Music]
people
dear no
[Music]
dear dear dear
but I do what I do
with a second
and I participate want to I still quite want
glasses
back to mass appeal
and
no
sir
dear
June
this
that
[Music]
again
not
[Music]
no
best part
[Music]
[Applause]
no